it seems to me that the personal
evolutionary process in other words the
looping that I described in the last
chapter takes place in five distinct
steps first have clear goals second
identify and don't tolerate the problems
that stand in the way of you achieving
your goals
third accurately diagnose the problems
to get at their root causes fourth
design plans that will get you around
those problems and fifth do what's
necessary to push those designs through
to completion together these five steps
make up a loop let's look at this
process more granularly first you have
to pick what you're going after in other
words your goals your choice of goals
will determine your direction as you
move toward them you will encounter
problems some of those problems will
bring you up against your own weaknesses
how you react to the pain that causes is
up to you if you want to reach your
goals you must be calm and analytical so
that you can accurately diagnose your
problems design a plan that will get you
around them and do what is necessary to
push through to results then you will
have to look at the new results you
achieve and go through the process again
to evolve quickly you will have to do
this fast and continuously setting your
goals successively higher you will need
to do all five steps well in order to be
successful and you must do them one at a
time and in that order for example when
setting goals just set goals don't think
about how you will achieve them or what
you will do if something goes wrong when
you are diagnosing your problems don't
think about how you will solve them just
diagnose them blurring the steps leads
to suboptimal outcomes because it
interferes with uncovering the true
oops